اليوم حنا متواجدين في واجهه الرياض
الحضور العرض الاول في السعوديه لفيلم
نبيل جميل اخصائي تجميل حضور الفنان محمد
هنيدي وعدد من الفنانين والاعلاميين
الفيلم فكره الفنان محمد هنيدي ومن تاريخ
محمد المحرز وامين جمال ومن اخراج خالد
مرعي
النهارده في البرد
انا يا ستي دكتور بكبر اسخره اشد انفخ كده
الفيلم بطوله النجم محمد هنيدي والنجمه
نور اللبنانيه بجانب عدد من الفنانين منهم
محمد سلام ومحمود حافظ و رحمه احمد واحمد
فؤاد احداث الفيلم في اطار كوميدي تشويقي
عن دكتور نبيل اخصائي التجميل وهو هنيدي
الذي يمتلك غاده للتجميل ومن خلال تلك
العياده يتعرض للعديد من المواقف وتحدث
بينه وبين النور دكتور التجميل العديد من
المفارقات الكوميديه ههه
نبيل الجميل شباب دكتور طموح بيبدا من
الصفر وبينجح ولكن رحلته الدراميه مليئه
بالكوميديا الحمد لله في سمعه جايه من
القاهره على الفيلم فالناس همم هنا
متسوقين اكثر الاجانب الجمهور السعودي
جمهور مش محتاج يعني كان مسرح وقت بشكل
عالي ففرحان وفرحان اكثر ان انا اول مره
اتفرج مع الناس اه
اه
الفيلم ابتدا بمصر ب 28 ديسمبر كان محطم
من الارقام كل الارقام القياسيه بالقاهره
وان شاء الله احنا عملنا كبير انه شعب
الرياض بحب هنيدي وهي كل الاقمار شديد جدا
على الفن سوف يعرض في جميع صلاه السينما
في السعوديه ابتداء من يوم الخميس 12
يناير القادم وتذاكر متاحه للحجز من الان
ومن المتوقع ان يحضر الفيلم بصدى واسع
خلال الايام القادمه صباح العربيه محمد
خالد الرياض